allora che se il primo video che faccio
con lo studio nuovo così ho preso una
persona che mimava nuova la quella ruota
qua questa qualche baby poi ci scriverò
le robe e usciranno per credere
una di queste sarà chiama giampiero e
manda l'affondo di tu arriverai a dei
giorni ogni volta che chiama tu non puoi
non rispondere ma la sta roba è piaciuta
un'idea geniale più il quando io invito
i miei amici ea giocare allora ce ne
facciamo che far le cose difficili mi
faccia oggi facciamo solo impossible ko
negli impossible si muore se vorrai st
lucenti altro e poi impossible giant man
by john cena oggi facciamo domanda e tu
e siccome tu o mio dio questo è
un'immagine veramente terrificante
hammami ha però e sono vivo solo il
rischio di morire perché mi è capitato
così come tu monti happy with fatti una
domanda ma esattamente qual è il livello
più ostico da montare ostico nel mio
cognome ai tempi era lo spy poi perché
no scusami rock swing perché dopo un po
erano rottura di balle a del como nodo
romea monotono secondo me è boltro il
massimo contro la rottura si è il
massimo della noia veramente dell'anci
palle fino a quando non entrino perché
non è questo non sto facendo stessa cosa
ma non solo lanciandosi ministro se
questo sia un altro ma era veramente
tipici smarca caso detto che un fenomeno
ovviamente impossible servais come sono
aspetta che diciamo che quello di alcuni
che non ho fatto io sono cranico
sarà niente arriva comunque ragazzi line
io mi incazzo con te perché non è vero
che non puoi insegnare migliore e più è
il mio esatto è questo ciò che tu sei
veramente forte perché ho giocato a
questo per 180 episodi punto avrei
veramente forte probabilmente ho giocato
più a the peawees di quanto io abbia
studiato in tutta la mia vita però sono
molto non devi dirle queste cose oggi
non funzionanti una vita gioconda ping
io sono gli istituti sì sì sì sono io
decido io se dovessi spendere le mille
ore che spesso dure per i giovani da
happy ulisse riprendendomi non sarei non
saresti attenzione spiegami fisicamente
impossibile e una giampiero del futuro
metti una musica di workout assassino
sarebbe stato bellissimo aggrapparsi
quale fare questo dice ci provi sempre
ovvero sarebbe veramente difficile che
brucia si può fare con cui tra queste
super smash nota scritta io dovrei fare
il giro prendendo la bomba liquami oddio
no no niente gli ha staccato bravo
comunque niente ragazzo era mai visto
che stanno facendo il 2 si perché hai
montato le ha inferto questo è stato né
news incredibile non vedo l'ora che una
donna chissà cosa sono spalle per
mettere un po per altri sette anni che
campo io ragazzi campa giampiero quindi
serie c simpatico giampiero ragazzi e
jam path iglo san piero ok non a caso
sta veramente lì a partiti che questa è
veramente dino queste in possesso di
pellet era impossibile ma cosa ma com'è
possibile non si foro è assurdo però
guarda è affranto non è male solo
affranto e molto tempo tutto triste
statistica gianni in sottofondo
lo dicevo la la cosa più bella la
montagna alta per me sono imposti col
perché mi fossero mi fa ridere vedere
che ci prova a farli e poi comunque dopo
un po schifo verso il finale maledizione
alla vita è veramente difficile
grande gara 3 di skill ci costerà ben sa
veramente di possibili
il problema è che devi arrivare ogni
volta a un livello diverso e ma non ci
arrivi sono vivo come no non sono uscita
non ci hanno detto sono previste su un
costruire le diviso come giorgio in
parte forte 12 tele 90 giorni chissà
forse parole fissati madonna veramente
non sto dormendo ricordare giorgio si
sia all una e mezza ed in ottenga
bellissima quando ho mosso dormendo ora
è possibile che sia rinato tutti sì se
arriva dell'elezione matteo però
riuscito amica taglierai che la mia
vittoria perché ho fatto me toglier
metterai lo spoiler cordura c'e nessuno
bravo oramai ragazzi questo ragazzo è
diventato incredibili e credibile il
clean
no ma basta lo stop bat fa proprio paura
tra l'altro è veramente tu puoi
utilizzare il tuo paolo forma che scena
per la ghigliottina e poi la famiglia
ecco neanche io sarebbe già vissuto
questa è finalmente nella nostra
attenzione si è stato molto brava non
sfileranno in futuro se aiuto sempre
tonica mamma finalmente morto quello
apposto grande detto che non solo non
solo sono stato molto bravo anche detto
john badham chissà quante altre robe si
sentano notizie brano incredibile tanto
è piaciuto facevo fare il lodo lo sfondo
su con giorgio lavori giganti che tanto
voi non vedete nemmeno l'ho fatto vedere
nel video di ieri ma non si vedono
cioccolato resta pensione ragazzi questo
di imporsi col veramente impossibile è
morto questa è un'opera d'arte
red gav così quello di prima si no sono
tutti diversi e che sei già calato nel
mio cervello guarda tu credi cioè come
sai dirmi no non ti posso di mussi
insegnare tutto tranne che è adesso di
rai come fai a no avevo fatto una
schivata di quelle pazzesche c'era già
la [ __ ] fuori la mia prima gara
incredibile secondo te quante reti con
una media di 45 minuti a episodio 133
ore but no impossibili sì sì vero perché
se il pc pensiero che non solo per
registrare però 133 ore di rec numero
133 euro è troppo bonus e non nome del
gioco molto di più no comunque no è così
perché se c'è ad esempio rocket league
io c'ho 209 di 300 ore però rocket
league
gioco per i cavoli miei solo di rex solo
reg
solo vecchio rosa la 20 ma neanche vero
orco demonio perché devi farci vedere
sky io di operando con quale la testa 24
amg devi solo premere tasto ok impennati
un po gli impegnativi mandare indietro
immagini
ok gli e trovo dell'arti di per dire no
mai ok hai capito quanto è difficile
giocare adempimenti meta ma occhio che
ce l'ho ce l'ho
no proprio la tecnica fotografica no
anche perché devo avere il giusto timing
era buono tutto prima il casco tutto il
resto ai occhio aspetti laniera era
soltanto per questo la peggio da fare
no basta però farei un primo tentativo
no caro 5 cd questa roba che sono bravo
in queste cagate si è mai capito
ti prego fammi capire primi attori si
muovo battelli guarda se io non esploso
ma di attenzione
no no c'è un po la faccia e la pratica
di gemonio
sarà lui è fatta dai grande renato
calcola ci abbiamo messo tanti
tantissimi ragazzi questo era il primo
video con uno sfondo anche se si vedeva
poco perché c'erano in due però spero
che vi sia piaciuto questa non
impossibile prossimo video farò un 10
minuti di non mi ricordo cosa manca ho
scritto che parte noi faremo in dieci
minuti di qualcosa per batter nuovo
record fateci sapere se video che giunti
si chiede a canestro campale mila e non
è come sempre ci vediamo e non mi
ricordavo un prossimo video bene ragazzi
[Musica]